all right guys
bang bang i have a very special treat
for you today cliff is here
and uh he's one of the rare people who
comes on and uh he's done the work
he's uh he's run a real business scaled
it been super successful so thank you so
much for uh for taking the time to come
on and
talk hey good to be with you today and i
appreciate the opportunity
for sure let's just start with your
background um you
grew up where got into law and
eventually ended up at sonic but kind of
tell us the story of how you get to
uh to the business so um
grew up in north texas um until
finished elementary school adolescent
years was spent in oklahoma city
kind of a pivotal point of really
formative in my life
um we my family moved from wichita falls
to oklahoma city
after my dad lost his business um due to
a variety of circumstances um
but he lost the business he lost
everything um
i was 11 going on 12 and uh to see that
in my family literally lose our home
you know and um that was
impactful for well all my life you know
and uh i remember when my youngest kid
was 11 years old
and then i told him you know when i was
your age
we were evicted from our home and
he my my kid just couldn't believe it
just couldn't fathom the concept you
know
so anyway he took a sales job in
oklahoma city
uh that was he was better off being at
the intersection of i-40
and interstate 35 so we moved to
oklahoma city
and within two or three years he was
back in business for himself he was
really a serial entrepreneur
and um very impressive the way he
recovered
but um at any rate so uh on the plains
north texas oklahoma
uh um here through undergraduate school
went east
for five years was in washington dc took
a law degree at georgetown university
lived in baltimore maryland for a couple
years practiced law while my wife was in
graduate school there
then we returned to the plains my big
idea just because the economy was so hot
and what i didn't realize it was
overheated by a
by a oil boom that was debt fueled
and so within a year after our moving
back all that came unwound
i spent a couple of years in a business
law practice here but i saw that
going i saw it going down because
because the economy is going down so um
my view was i either uh had the um
opportunity to um try to get maybe get
inside a company that wasn't tied to the
oil business
or frankly leave the region
and at this point i was um late twenties
my wife was still in graduate school
she'd continue on with her studies she's
a
epidemiologist and eventually became a
you know
phd in epidemiology but uh i decided i
need to kind of stay here and help
um help support her get through that
process
so i left what private law practice went
to science at like
i was 29 years old so here i was i mean
amazing enough 29 years old and
general counsel of a public company
called sonic
how i got into business our company went
through two lbos
to talk about that in the book went
through two lbos in the late 80s
we took it public in the early 90s i was
central to all of those
in terms of helping orchestrate them and
um
and and then after we went public i
decided i was going to leave the company
told the ceo
and this is a compressed version of the
story but
once i told him i was going to leave he
said well why don't you stay here and
run the company
and so i became ceo and it was a gradual
process in terms of learning about the
company
from the time i joined the company until
i became ceo it was
it was like nine years so it's not like
it happened overnight
but i had an opportunity to really learn
the business
and uh um and so that's how i got onto
the business side
and a year and a half i'd say after i
became ceo
i was running the company day my boss
left
and uh you know rather suddenly but he
left the company and the board turned to
me and said you want to be ceo and
i thought well i'm already running the
company so why not
and same day they named me ceo and and i
was ceo for the next 23 years
so so when you come in as the general
counsel and you eventually become the
ceo
those are two very different functions
yeah but
you're doing it at a time when uh
there's multiple transactions going on
uh the company's growing talk through a
little bit just as to
uh in hindsight what were the key pieces
uh
either of learning um or people that
helped you transition from that general
counsel role into eventually the ceo
role and then kind of set you up for
success to thrive as the ceo of sonic
great yep so um uh
so um one i gotta say
uh uh i think one of the biggest factors
was uh i was young
[Music]
and because of that when i joined sonic
i've been practicing law four years if
i've been practicing law 20 years
i not might not have been malleable
enough to move over the business side
but i was 29 and it was just relatively
small company
and i was aggressive and curious and
always pushing out you know so
um uh the team was light from a
management you know quantity and quality
of management
and so it really meant that i was often
able to fill a void
uh on special projects and so on but it
also meant that when he wanted to buy
the company
uh you know a cfo might have stepped in
but we won we didn't have a cfo
technically and um uh
this meant that i really just got to
learn the business
um my boss wanted to buy the
company and um
uh he wouldn't do that from the outset
but it was that was hard to pull off
but he i think part of his thought in
hiring me with a business background and
then maybe expectations beyond an
ordinary lawyer from the standpoint of
just life expectations i don't know
anyway he he saw me somebody could help
him do that
so the process is to a great degree i
joined the company in 84 and 86 we did
buy the company
and and to do that to structure that and
and
sell it to lenders and so on and so
forth it really did
um take more understanding of how we
made money didn't make money how we
how we could change that going forward
and because the company was hit a bit of
a low point when he joined the company
and i joined the company
um but we were able to buy it in
um i got uh invested you know as a
stockholder so
they gave me a little bit different view
of things by
within two years we had a lot of
motivation contractual
motivation to buy out our institutional
partner that had joined us in 86.
uh at three years into the deal the
price was going to go up
and by the besides that they wanted out
they need to show a return to their
investors
so um uh two years into having bought
the company we restructured the
ownership
and and um and i was able to pull out a
lot of
of my investment i able to pull out a
severe multiple of what i put in
two years before and you know suddenly
this gets your attention because
in that 88 recap not only i mean just to
give you
and i talked about this in the book it
was all public too
but i i am in in cash out of pocket
in 86 i put out in 2500 bucks
and two years later i pulled out over
600 000
and so one was the leverage with the
leverage buyout and two was the
turnaround that started occurring and
the value of the company was exploding
so
suddenly here i am early 30s now i've
got a kid
my wife and i uh had had our first son
we're both 30
and um so
now i'm now i'm part a larger part of a
company
larger ownership i went from one percent
ownership to eight percent ownership and
had pulled out
this capital which you know here on the
planes during an oil bus
watching bankruptcies all around me that
was an extraordinary
thing in my life so it gave me a little
bit more motivation to
come to understand this thing and um
a couple years into it our new
institutional partners want to take it
public for their own purposes
they want to liquefy so they turn to me
they said advise the team on how to go
how to go public
so i took a central role in that for the
next you know year and more
and we were successful in taking public
so once again two lbos and ipo
dealing with all aspects of this but
particularly
from a corporate finance standpoint i
didn't have a finance background
but i've gotten extraordinary you know
on job training
you would say um and uh so this was my
introduction to the business and
thinking more like business
and how to you know strategizing about
growth of the business
what would i do with the team meaning
the management team
you know if they were my management team
who would go who would grow
and so and so forth so this was
this kind of seven or eight years after
i joined the company it actually wasn't
a short circuited stuff earlier it was
in 92 that my boss came to me and said
you've been general counsel for eight
years how would you like to be cfo
then and it was pretty sarbanes-oxley
and
and i kind of thought fine this should
be
this would i'd learn more doing this had
good
team in place and you know good uh
auditors and so on
good board so i said yes to that and
then it was a year later when i said
okay i'm going to leave and he said no
no become ceo and just run the company
so um this was it was a gradual process
but a very real one of personal and
professional development for me
before i was made before i was made ceo
yeah it's a fantastic story uh while you
were running the business both the ceo
and then eventually ceo
uh the business had pretty explosive
growth it went from you know just over a
thousand stores i think to over
uh 4 000 locations uh drive-in sales
you know up uh double digits uh you know
year over year
um and just by all measures uh a very
successful
uh oversight of the business and the
growth that it enjoyed
what was the secret to success was it
improving the product
was it better marketing was it investing
in the brand uh was it just
simply hiring great people like when you
look back and you said we had this you
know epic run
of success here is the playbook what do
you say
well in a way all those things you just
listened um
the answer was yes yes yes yeah
so a series of things that came together
just as i um just as i became ceo
and then you know the question is what
do you do with them but we we we drove
them like crazy
so what what were two of the things that
came together
okay i should say three but they all
they played in a huge way
uh the first was while i was ceo
i conducted over a 13-month period i
conducted a license renegotiation
with our franchisees with our franchise
leadership
because um the the licenses
were coming to closure in the late 90s
and our franchise leadership and us but
really our franchise europe was very
concerned about that
because they did not want to get to the
end of the license agreement
and then you know all of them have
scores of stores that
you know could lose their licenses so
they wanted
years in advance to renegotiate this and
we were willing to because we built the
value of the brand
so this was 93 94 and i just moved into
the coo
role literally as that as that began
and so 13 month process um the
franchisees felt like it was painful
i felt like it was enormously successful
because they got what they wanted we got
what we wanted
they wanted uh elongated terms
and they wanted more protected trade
radius around their stores
um meaning a little enlarged it was one
mile and they wanted to
larger in different circumstances and so
on so those are their two big points in
negotiation
longer term better protection trade rate
is around the store
uh we wanted more authority as a
franchisor
modern franchisor which we didn't have
and
authority to require you know single
agency for advertising
authority to require buying off of a
single contract for goods across the
system
authority to require every few years of
a trade dress upgrade at the store level
so we got all these things in there plus
we we got a modern
rate royalty rate uh which has had been
quite outdated as well
so that was that was
one thing um simultaneously that we were
leading them through a process to talk
about where does this brand need to go
and and the two fit together perfectly
because the license agreement gave us
the authority
in a way it's a this difference in
authority of uh du jour versus de facto
disturbing the law
de facto being you know building a
credibility street cred with folks you
know
and so um the authority we
were building we it really in a way had
both of those because the new license
agreement was
the disjoint the new license was the law
that we had
but a process that we were taking the
whole system through meetings to talk
about
facilities and in uniforms and
menu inconsistencies and so on was the
street cred piece
so that by the time we reached the
finish point on this street cred piece
we had a new menu we had new uniforms we
had a retrofit coming down the pike they
knew they had to do
and these two were beautiful because we
engaged them in the de facto process
but they knew the whole time that we had
this new license agreement and we if we
had to we had the hammer
but we didn't want to use that of course
so these are the two of the
the strongest things but i would also
say from a people standpoint
we had a marketing person in paddy moore
and with the new dollars we got from the
license renegotiation we rebuilt several
parts of our company including our
purchase and distribution
and we we bring in it brought in then a
guy named drew ricker
and and uh drew was fantastic
on on negotiating with these new
requirements we had under the license
agreement that everybody
buy from the national contracts patty
started driving
same store sales with some new
promotional activities because we
required under that new license
agreement new deal everybody had to be
on the same menu
so and and and by the way
this is so licensed renegotiation
strategic focus with the marketing and
and more broadly and then
a third element franchisee and i say
this in the book
94 a franchise he came to me and said
you got to help me out
and he was a good operator and i said
why what's the problem
he said some of your i got a great
program that's helped me said things are
healthy in texas and oklahoma but
they're not healthy in the carolinas
and i got a great program that's keeping
me alive and your guys are telling me to
shut it down
i said well tell me about the program
and so he proceeds to tell me about an
ice cream program he's got
and i say to him well what does your top
store do with this ice cream program he
said well my top store does 30
of its sales and ice cream i said you
must be kidding me
i said well tell me more i said don't
change anything i'm going to send our
marketing folks out there
and you show them what we're doing what
you're doing
and so we did and a year later we rolled
the thing out we didn't shut them down
we rolled it out across the whole system
now so here what we have is new
authority under the license agreement to
require retrofits and this kind of stuff
and by 96 we have sales
exploding but more so profit exploding
because we've got this new frozen
fountain favorites menu
and and so profits begin exploding 96
into 97
and we can require everybody to do the
single promotions
across the system and we've now brought
on this retrofit and so once you get
into
i was became ceo in 95 in
in in 96
and 96 you start getting some benefit of
drew rickers purchasing
97 the drinks and ice cream come into
play
average store profits from 96 to 97
jumped 40 percent
for the operator i'm going to talk about
the company i'm talking about the
average
operator what was then 12 or 1400 stores
jobs 40 in one year these franchisees
were suddenly just rolling in the dome
so what does this feed
it fed rapid roll out of a retrofit
across the entire system
and what else did it feed rapid
expansion of new stores
and and um and then we've negotiated
under the license agreement an ascending
royalty rate
we said okay we've got the old-time
royalty rate but if we grow your sales
we want a higher royalty rate
and so we as a franchisor started
getting disproportionately positive
benefit from all this
and so and so anthony when you talk
about this
run up when i lesson left the system it
was begin to push 5 billion in sales
but when i became ceo it was about 800
million
in 1997 we hit for the first time ever
1 billion in 19 system-wide sales
all stores franchise included 1 billion
and 97.
it had taken 44 years for the business
to get 1 billion
four years later we doubled it to 2
billion this is the consequence of this
kind of compounded
same store sales new news stories etc
the the business just exploded and we
had 97 we had a billion 0-1 we had 2
billion and 0-5 we had 3 billion
so it was on a tear you know
and as a result so was the company and
we split our stock
from from 96 to 06 we split our stock of
three
or two stocks but we split it six times
in ten years
and it it was it was just on a tear
it was a great run it was fun yeah and
obviously the suspect the success that
you had uh
not only gave you a bunch of experience
and skills but
uh this book that you wrote uh master of
none um
i think the part to me that stuck out
the most wasn't so much
the individual stories or the experience
or the skills
it was the mindset and almost like the
philosophical take you have on business
and literally master of none uh is kind
of a counter-intuitive uh
type piece of advice where most people
say hey you need to be an expert right
you need to be an expert in the law to
be the general counselor you need to be
an expert in finance to be the cfo
or you need to be have an mba and be an
expert in business to run the actual
business
you seem to have drastically benefited
from
actually being well-rounded and not
having just one expertise but kind of
having
a command of multiple disciplines talk a
little bit about
why that's been so important to you and
your career and how that made you
successful
well uh so uh the title book is master
of none the subtitle
is how a jack of all trades can still
reach the top
so in some ways in this book the
subtitle is is
equally important to the title if not
even more so but you know this is a
that'd be an awfully long title to the
book how jack all trades can still reach
the top
so it kind of turned it upside down at
any rate
um so uh has it been important to me
uh i'd say it has been all my life
because i as
growing up i was active and formally
in music many ways church music and
and school programs music programs at
school
but i was also active in sports and you
know i
i i excelled in each um i was also
a good student unfortunately i was a
good student often without trying
hard and uh i might have
really in all my endeavors i might have
benefited from somebody
pushing me harder but usually when so i
pushed i walked away
you know so uh i
i was an avid reader good student um
uh you know what in my book i talk about
really
one of my first leadership positions
which would not be customary i think you
think about a
an executive that was a public public
company
my first leadership position was
president of the voice of glee club you
know when i was a
junior when i was in junior high i was
in eighth grade
and um that actually was the confidence
that my teacher placed in me really kind
of
helped my self-concept evolved to in a
positive way
fairly quickly that was a very nice
thing at 13 14 years old
um but um you know what was my next run
of leadership
it really was student student government
in my high school
setting in no small ways because the
high school was
undergoing a tremendous rapid change
because of court ordered desegregation
and so that was a huge growing
experience for me
um so but i've always had a wide degree
of wide
a degree of interest you know i enjoy
not unlike a lot of people i enjoy food
enjoy travel
um but so i think coming into the
business
i probably discounted my ability or my
capacity to move into a leadership
position because i didn't see it as
leadership i viewed it as business
management i didn't have business
education
my undergraduate degree was in history
my graduate degree was in law
i did go into business law granted but
it's the difference between business law
in in in business school you know
had no mba and but what i didn't
appreciate was that i had
good education from a standpoint of
critical thinking
um in some ways
history and law can are good
counterparts to each other
because the history does let you go back
and see
you know where um events occurred
and can be analyzed in such a ways to
you know
draw conclusions or see different paths
that might have occurred
you know historically had leaders done
one thing or another
um law is an analytical piece of
of finding similarities or where people
don't other people don't see them or
are finding distinctions where others
think that the situations are identical
and and uh the business law is a little
bit different from
uh trial work but in many ways the
critical thinking that's
that forces you through going through a
legal education really
makes that kind of separation and the
critical
critical thinking piece moved to a very
different level
so i think these really aided me when i
got into business because
as opposed to not wanting to look back
some people don't as opposed to not want
to look back and do a post morning on
something you
post mortem on something you screwed up
my reaction is no you must go back and
look at what you screwed up to not
repeat it
so it was a different approach i think
to understanding the business and how
you could manage it
so i was i think i was always a
generalist
i enjoyed you know i played piano but
but didn't take lessons i played guitar
but i didn't take lessons
you know and um
so this was this was just kind of me you
know
and so as i look back over my career i
did
in business career i did rely on strong
people i had good teams
i delegated effectively brought them
resources
worked hard to keep things aligned in
terms of objectives and
activities i i say that because what i'm
what i'm saying is
functional behavior in an organization
keep the team aligned and to make sure
that adequate resources are placed in
order to drive
the specific direction and so as i look
back at my career late my career and
then thinking about
the stories and you know considering a
book
i i did come to see myself as a business
leader
and okay i had to be a good manager here
and there and throughout
but the main thing i saw was i was
running a franchise organization
uh small independent operators of our
concept
who were very independent-minded and you
had to find ways to sell them
continuously on staying alive
you couldn't just order them you could
but that's a that's a short-term gain
so um i i think over time i can look
back and
see the um you know kind of with that
that arc of history in my own life enjoy
enjoying a wide array of activities
and not seeing that as an impediment
to growing a company like sonic instead
seeing
as a as a foundation
for a good leader and and seeing it as
an empowering
uh element of my own life rather than a
limiting
element that that jack of all trades
yeah one of the things you talk about is
kind of this like narrow focus
is unsafe and boring and so i think
that's like a really
interesting framework because the boring
part is
uh more a personal enjoyment
right of just who wants to be bored
their whole life
doing one thing right but the right the
unsafe part i think
is counterintuitive to people so
describe a little bit why you think of
it as
unsafe to have a narrow focus more
rather than a
more generalist or broad view of the uh
uh business world
well i think a lot of this depends upon
the area you want to go into
in life because if you do decide you
want to be a brain surgeon
um then then i think you you better get
pretty specific about what you're
studying
and what you're doing every day on the
other hand
uh if you decide you want to um go into
even even something technical let's just
say
in the technology world you better
approach it with some flexibility
because the pace of change there is so
fast
that if you are narrow with what you
approach even in the technology field
um you know if you're narrowing what
you're approaching you could be
irrelevant
in two years you know so from my
standpoint
um you know my view kind of back up and
get off the brain surgeon thing or
you know uh at 12 years old i mean i
thought i was gonna be a cleanup
uh batter for the yankees but by the
time i was 15 i knew that wasn't going
to be true you know
so so what's my prep and so from my
standpoint it was
gonna get a good education about how the
world works
and um and and as i said also the
critical thinking skills
and um use these skills
to be open
to opportunities that come along
and ones that feel right for me
intuitively feel right that i can
embrace
but the the um so
in the book yes the discussion about
being too narrow can can do two things
one
the world can just bypass you but the
other thing is to the extent you're too
narrow
your head's down to focus not your
head's not out you're not keeping
options open
opportunities can pass you by um
so my belief is with
being that generalist and keeping your
head up
and being open to new opportunities
you you you got to be able to see those
opportunities to seize them
um yeah i think it's the narrow person
who thinks they can create their
opportunities for themselves
i think most opportunities we don't
create what we do is prepare
and then the old adage that
fortune favors the prepared you know
and so if you are prepared it looks like
you're lucky
or whatever but if you're prepared your
head's up and your eyes are open
uh you can seize opportunities they come
along that you would never see otherwise
and i think the more narrow you are or
narrowly prepared and more narrow in
your work
more likely to have your head down
narrowly focused you're going to miss
opportunities
and there's also a better chance the
world's just going to blow past you
as your skills become irrelevant so
that's the gist of the book i think
and at least that portion of it yeah and
the part to me that
seems so interesting is like this idea
of exploration leads to
breakthrough right like you if you just
sit and do the same thing every day
it's very unlikely that you were going
to have any major breakthrough
created any sort of significant
inflection point uh but that exploration
that intellectual curiosity really kind
of carries the day is that fair to say
i think that's fair to say a lot of it
is intellectual curiosity
you got to be a curious person about how
the world works and what's
what's about what may be about to occur
why it's going to occur
and how you're going to handle that
you're going to embrace it you're going
to avoid it
yeah and so i think uh
being curious and open those two
elements are
two of the most critical elements of
having a um a rich life
i think yeah and in your profession or
personally if you do the opposite
you know closed and not curious you're
gonna have far less interesting business
career but also a little
less interesting life for sure is there
anything that you've done
um or anything that you can suggest to
people in terms of how to
increase intellectual curiosity right
like for you and i who i think are
generally uh or naturally intellectually
curious people
uh we can just say hey be intellectually
curious but there's some people who just
that's not their inclination
anything that you could think of that
could help people become more curious or
kind of at least
get started down that path well
it depends upon who
you are who i am that you're talking
about if you talk about
within an organization as an example
i often very often work to make sure
that
i was including um a broad cross-section
of our team
in in all kinds of activities so so as
to get
a good functional behavior a good
integration of effort
and work as hard as possible not to have
silos
so this is if i take your question be
what could a
person who's already leading an
organization do to help the organization
achieve what you're talking about you
know i mean one of the things that i did
is not so uncommon now but 20 years ago
it was
we were designing a new headquarters
building and
the building is not what has to be new
it's the layout that is different
but i'd been uh i've been by the time we
were designing this i've been
ceo of the company six or seven years we
are in a
um high-rise downtown maine in maine
i had top floor corner office private
bathroom marble floors you had to go
through my secretary space to get to me
um and what i found was the longer that
when it went on
the more horribly boring it was i mean
the job the ceo is isolated you're
isolated enough and it's lonely enough
as it is
if you make it physically isolated
physically alone it's even worse
you know so we were designing new space
i i had um picked up and visiting a
couple other
ceos in their their businesses a
different way to approach that
and i kind of pulled together combined
elements of what i saw in these other
places so when we designed this new
space
i i designed it first of all so there's
not a single corner office in the whole
building
every corner was a was a conference room
secondly um uh chain went to modular
furniture so it wasn't about who got to
fight over what size desk or what size
chair
everybody in the whole place had the
same chair i had the same chair
as everybody else and my floor was not
in the corner why not even on south
florida i went to a
middle floor and i sat in the middle of
the building
i had a desk out on an open floor using
the same chair everybody else used
if i needed privacy behind my
open desk was a was a room
that had a clear glass on all four sides
and so that if i needed quote privacy i
stepped into my glass room
and then all the employees that were
going by could see
you know business being conducted etc
so my objective there was to blow up
the silos and have the physicality of
the
of the office space work against
building silos
so that all employees could see each
other every day
and it was an enormous contributor to
just that
and so but you can find processes as an
executive leader you can find processes
to
break down walls to increa include
people
from other disciplines and keep projects
that you have and so on and so forth
okay
well that's the executive leader for the
individual
you know um uh uh you know i i think
within an organization
an individual can you know what you can
do individually of course is just
explore things through reading or
uh or or hobbies or otherwise to get
into areas
you're not naturally comfortable with
but within an organization
you know volunteer for task forces even
proposed task forces that are cross
functional within the organization make
sure you get into
those task forces that you meet other
people in the company
that you engage in tasks that are beyond
your department
beyond your comfort level to help you
grow
et cetera so it is a question of
acting on your curiosity it's one thing
to have the
curiosity it's the other thing not to
act on it because you don't act on it
then
you know okay well it's an academic
point so
uh but if you're if you are a naturally
curious person and you're in an
organization that's run
as silos and there's no way around it
well you know
you probably need to look for a new
employer but um
uh otherwise i think you you work to try
to break down the silos work
cross-functional manner
then this i think can be really
stimulating for a curious person
yeah it's so fascinating to hear about
uh that glass room that you had where
you would uh kind of step in for privacy
uh when i worked at facebook uh mark
zuckerberg had one and we called it the
fishbowl or the aquarium right because
basically kind of you
feel a little bit like you're inside of
that and uh and it was fascinating
because you know somebody who's the
executive of a large company
uh can go in there for a phone call can
go in and meet somebody that nobody
knows
uh or literally at one point the prime
minister of india came
and sat there right and everyone's
walking by and and you know
uh kind of see the um yeah the business
being conducted as you mentioned
so it it it does uh have a very
different effect
than uh oh the ceo's offices up on the
top floor right it's almost like the
physical proximity
um that can have an impact when you
think today
uh for a young leader um who aspires to
kind of have
the successful career that you've had um
what is the advice if you were mentoring
them
what are the things outside of what
we've talked about already that you kind
of just
hey keep this in the back of your head
or these are the things that i wish i
knew when i first got started
that you would share with those young
leaders
well i depend on the organization
depending on what you're wanting to
pursue
but you're describing it as an
organizational leader so by definition
it this sounds like feels like um
a circumstance in which the you know the
generalists can
can benefit um rather than the
their the narrow specialists so i think
they
you know at a really younger age
the issue is get a good education and
and um
um particularly in aries and on paths
that do
demand you know critical thinking skills
and analytical skills
um uh beyond that um
uh you know life is not target practice
you know life's a journey you know
so don't try to aim at something that
you think is going to enhance your
path uh listen to your instincts
about uh so in other words your
intuition
you know what what sounds right to you
what feels right to you
and go on a path where things click for
you
you know instead of trying to pursue
something that you think
um from an external standpoint
you know on a resume or whatever
something that looks good
you know pursue something that that
feels
right to you from your own intuition and
and your your own talent and skill sets
and and then beyond that uh remain
open to opportunity that comes along
keep your head up
eyes open remain open to opportunity
[Music]
uh one fellow that um
uh i talked to about my book he endorsed
import and
endorse the book and i had him in my
home podcast bill from
out of kansas city that has formed
several companies
in kansas city that are headquartered in
kansas city including those
international scope bill makes the point
uh you know just say yes you know which
is title one of my chapters
just say yes because his comment is well
when you say no the door is closed
yeah and whereas if you say yes
um uh and you know if you learn a month
or two later
six months later that you just really
can't pursue this path you can always go
back to somebody and say
listen i gotta shoot straight with you i
thought we could do this but i don't
think we can do this you know
i thought i could cut this but i think
we need this additional talent
whatever but the point is um
learn how to say yes to opportunity and
and figure out how to do it because if
you say yes you're going to get full
engagement if you say no you just close
the door
um so these are these are thoughts along
the way to a
person younger in their career the other
things that you would say are a little
bit more obvious and they're
they're they're almost jingoistic but
they're true and that is
you know work hard
and do the job right you know and make
sure the job gets done
well uh but those are somewhat generic
but they're accurate
now because if a person thinks that i
got my college degree and now somebody
owes me something
you know they're going to be a little
surprised a little disappointed
you know with that with that mindset one
of my favorite business stories ever
is uh the gentleman who ended up coming
up with hot cheetos
um he was a a janitor at the uh
at the business before he uh he came up
with that idea and uh he tells the story
that
um he was working somewhere else and he
gets the job as the janitor
and on his first day as he's going to
work his grandfather says to him
you make sure that everyone in that
building knows that munez
you know mopped the floor right just
just basically do your job have pride in
the work that you do
and that's the advice he's getting
literally to go mop the floors
and one day later he ends up building
you know what ends up being a couple
hundred million dollar
uh product line for uh free delay and
yeah
i think that there's a lot of people who
say oh that's luck or you know that's
this or that and it's
no it's the same things that uh you took
to work with you around hard work and
pride in your work and things
right uh as a janitor he's now applying
to you know something that people
think is much more aspirational right
but it's the same exact qualities
yes and he he was also a guy who was in
within an organization where
you know he won he would keep his eyes
open because the ceo
i talk about that example in my own book
because the ceo
invited that kind of input he developed
it at home
you know based on kind of some street
food
experiences that it had and then called
the ceo
who took who who took his call yeah some
organizations that wouldn't occur
well it's like your ice cream story
right yes yes
yes exactly the people that were trying
to shut down
our franchisee on his ice cream were two
of the most senior people in our company
and they told him the reason he wasn't
going to do it was him just to say it
he they told him that's too much like
dairy queen
and we don't we don't want to do it and
yet today
my my i've been gone from sonic for two
years
but my hunch is that um at this point
um sonic has to be doing six or seven
hundred million dollars worth of ice
cream
and wow at that time as a system we
probably did 25 million
you know yeah but it wasn't just the
increase increase in sales
um my then cfo like to say anything
he said i love any promotion where it's
something mixed with air or water
you know because because the product
margins were just extraordinary
and um that's that's how with our frozen
fountain favorites
that we rolled out in 96 spring of 96
96 to 97 average store profits jumped 40
percent
unbelievable you know changed everything
but we did
you know back to your original question
we built on that built on that built-in
act
everything that occurred we used it to
leverage something else
and and the business just flat took off
just a
fascinating just different way to look
at the business over and over and over
again
yeah it's amazing uh i wrap up each
conversation with
uh three questions uh the first one is a
little bit more serious which is just
what is the most important book that
you've ever read
outside of obviously the one that you
wrote
most one of the most had kids say maybe
one of the most important books
i've read outside of the one i wrote
uh and just a book that sticks out in
your mind as having had an impact on you
well i remember as a kid reading a book
that
kind of showed that even a kid could
branch out
and do interesting and curious things
and didn't need to be limited by age or
circumstance
but i played baseball as a kid i enjoyed
baseball a lot
as a kid i read a book dave palmer's
diamond mystery
okay um a book about a a young ball
player
part ball player part sleuth and um
and uh it was um it was a fascinating
book that that uh
i mean it was appropriate for my age but
it really kind of one it got me into
enjoying reading all that much more
and two um kind of set me on a path that
uh you know you you can really be kind
of
quite aspirational but in my adult life
i've mostly read biographies
um and you know in some ways going back
to my 20s
a series by stephen ambrose on
on dwight eisenhower was
one of the more fascinating and
delightful uh
sets of books i'd ever read i think it
was either either a
two or three book series but ambrose was
a great author
and and i read i have read quite a few
pieces by him but
in some ways i'd say the eisenhower
biography was one of the
most enjoyable um then just watching his
life growing up on the plains and
and eventually becoming president united
states you know
it's absolutely incredible uh the second
question is a little bit more fun
um sleep so in 2020 i made a
massive uh focus on hey i probably
should sleep more i was one of these
people who was
flying around took 120 flights uh
literally i think was sleeping kind of
four or five hours a night
um and i met the uh the founder of eight
sleep and uh mateo was like hey man you
probably should sleep a little bit more
uh what is kind of your sleep routine uh
as the ceo of sonic and then uh since
you've left
is it something where you slept eight
hours every night it just kind of got
what she what you needed
how did you sleep i don't think i've
ever slept eight hours
a night regularly and i don't get more
than eight hours of sleep
but just a few times a year and
certainly not continuously
um i'd say you know so one thing i'd say
is
when i was at just going to my teen
years 11 12 13
years old i started delivering
newspapers
and this meant getting up three a.m
every morning
and delivering newspapers come back to
go back to bed at 5 00 a.m
um the number of nights now still where
i wake up at 3 a.m
work for a couple hours and go back to
bed at 5 00 a.m is more often than i
care to admit to but but this
is um this is a little bit of a pattern
i'd say in my years as being ceo that um
the most common deal was five to six
hours a night
of sleep maybe catching up a little bit
on the weekend
but five to six hours a night and um
i i try to get more than that now and i
and i enjoy
i enjoy getting i enjoy not having to
rush off to work
for saying but um uh whereas these days
working from home anyway but um
uh i i unfortunately still wake up at 3
a.m i work for a couple hours
but i also now go back to sleep often
for another three hours or so so
not uncommon for me to get seven hours
sleep now but it's um often
often prove it it's improving
i know the sleep experts would say look
you need continuously
but you know i can't do a whole lot
about it i wake up at 3am and i'm wide
awake
you know yeah i i don't fight it i don't
fight it anymore you know
i just get up and read or work on some
projects and
until i get sleepy and i go back to bed
and it usually is six
90 or 90 minutes or two hours of work
um yeah i get a lot of work done in that
two hours
nobody around to bother you yeah no
phones ringing no nothing
absolutely i love it uh the last
question is a little quirky one
uh aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
well uh it uh it's my first thought to
try to come up with some quip there but
uh
as quickly as i do i'll um i'll regret
it
so um i i do think the
um you know the universe is a
fascinating thing
and um um it's
hard for us to imagine you know what all
uh really is out there you know because
we are limited to our own
reality to the greatest degree and so we
try to reinvent things
you know even to the extent we think
about them being there we reinvent them
in our own
likeness you know so
uh on the one hand after saying
uh it's a big universe and the
likelihood that
this this globe is the only one with
life on it
that seems um
there's no reason to be believe that has
to be the case
you know um and on the other hand
uh the more
practical usage of aliens that we see in
movies and
you know other fearful sort of things um
i don't i have a hard time going there
you know
but um there are interesting things we
all see and read periodically about
things that appear in the heavens that
uh
lack can lack any explanation
um so so who knows i don't know
um i'm not into uh
the alien i'm not into thinking about
that or pursuing it
but nor do i totally discount so yeah i
i think that is the most rational way to
view it is
uh big world probably life somewhere but
uh i doubt that they
are the little green men that uh showed
up in uh in some movies so i think uh
i think you're more on it than than you
realize i just hope they're
i hope there if they come around they're
jacks of all trades you know
i love it cliff listen thank you so much
for your time i i've yeah i've read
through the book uh
master of none uh how a jack of all
trades can still reach the top
and uh it is absolutely fantastic and as
i started off the uh
conversation uh it's just very obvious
that you've done the work and
uh and you know frankly just thank you
for taking the time to write it all down
and share the knowledge with folks
because i think
uh you know folks like yourself who who
have literally decades of experience
building companies successfully
uh there's just so much information that
you have that you can share with others
so uh
highly recommend everyone go get it and
just thank you so much for uh for taking
time to write the book and didn't have
this
thank you anthony yeah well and i
appreciate that
being on your program today and and i'm
happy to be with you and happy to talk
about
uh one of the things i like to talk
about that is my business and my career
my book you know so
okay take care